the ann has sustained life-threatening
injuries these are the most serious
injuries that we see
in burn care she was in an enclosed
space a car as well as an apartment so
that allowed smoke as well as toxic
gases to build up with a high
concentration which attacked her airway
and prevented her from breathing so
she's most likely in a medically induced
coma
meaning that she's on heavy sedation and
she also has severe pain
from her burn injuries she has two
very significant serious
life-threatening injuries this video
showing the woman on a stretcher
flailing and according to neighbors
screaming at the time she may have been
conscious at the time
but most likely with the
level of smoke that she had held
consciousness would have
would have decreased over time she
sustained an inhalation injury which
means there was damage to her airway she
could not breathe on her own
and she also sustained
flame burns third degree burns which
require surgery whenever you're in an
enclosed space like a car or an
apartment or a house that allows smoke
and chemicals to build up
which damages the lungs and prevents you
from breathing on your own so the only
way to survive is have mechanical
ventilation artificial breathing for you
on a machine
that means that she cannot breathe at
home that she sustained smoke inhalation
she inhaled a lot of smoke which damaged
her airway
she had to be placed on mechanical
ventilations or she would have died at
the scene
so the first responder did an excellent
job getting her to
a medical facility
and then the appropriate treatment was
rendered on a mechanical ventilator so
she could breathe she's fighting for her
life
right now